legally this is all result yes it is and
how long has that been for only a couple
of weeks and now we've we've all signed
off on something and you're happy with
it I'm happy enough with it I'm not out
there trying to twist the knife at all
I'm trying to look at this with some
level of compassion some level of wisdom
but do you feel like you've been kicked
out of the family I do but I don't feel
that it was something that was my doing
but that's got to hurt it hurt for a
while I did walk around for a few months
with a very visceral reaction to that
Lindsey Buckingham has a 43-year history
with Fleetwood Mac he helped shape their
classic sound and wrote some of their
biggest hits in January the band was
honored at the Music hares benefit
Grammy weekend but it would be
Buckinghams last performance with
Fleetwood Mac two days later he heard
from their manager Irving Azoff called
me up and he was basically screaming at
me he was screaming at you he was
screaming at me on the phone saying
you've really done it this time and I
had no idea what he was talking about no
he said Stevie never wants to be on
stage with you ever again and I'm going
why was Lindsey effectively fired well
we don't use that word because I think
it's ugly band mates Mick Fleetwood and
Stevie Nicks blamed it on Buckinghams
reluctance to sign off on a new tour
this team wanted to get out on the road
and one of the members did not want to
go out on the road for a year
Buckingham insists he'd agreed to
postpone his own solo tour to join the
band
but he says Azoff told him Nick's didn't
like his behavior at the MusiCares event
that she complained he smirked behind
her when she gave her acceptance speech
it appeared to me that she was looking
for something to hang on on me in order
to instigate some kind of a coup Irving
told me a couple
days later that she'd given the band an
ultimatum and either I had to go or she
was gonna go do you have any sense of
why Stevie would have reached this point
I don't know none of it makes sense to
me
you know Fleetwood Mac the five of us
together is in my mind is a very sacred
thing Buckingham and Nick's were a duo
professionally and romantically when
they joined Fleetwood Mac together in
1975 but they broke up during the
recording of the landmark rumours album
the song go your own way is about their
breakup I was not the one doing the
leaving she left me but there was never
really any chance to get anything like
closure because that takes a perhaps
some some distance it means there's
stuff in there that you really haven't
ever quite resolved I would think so
how would you describe your relationship
with Stevie my relationship with Stevie
is fragmented you know I think there's
still a lot of love there over the years
have you two communicated outside of the
formal structure of the band at all sure
in sort of spurts though in 2011 when I
did my solo album seeds we so I spend a
ton of time over at her house and we got
along great I mean the chemistry is the
chemistry there is a chemistry there is
have you spoken to any of the babe I
have not actually spoken to any of the
band and it's been almost a year now
nobody nobody I have had only in the
last couple of weeks I have gotten an
email which I expected to get from
Christine McVie Buckingham and McVie
recorded an album together last year and
went on tour she wrote me an email and
basically said dearest Lindsay just know
that I had nothing to do with any of
this know that I you so much she said I
believe deep in in Stevie's heart that
she would like you to come home what did
you take that to me that maybe
underneath everything
Stevie would like to see me back already
that maybe she feels ambivalent about
what's going on
this could be just Christine expressing
wishful thinking or or expressing
something she thinks will make me feel
better
Buckingham says he's open to getting
back with Fleetwood Mac but isn't
expecting a reunion have you made peace
with the fact you might not oh yeah I'm
pretty much figuring that I won't
because you know most a lot of people
who know how convoluted Fleetwood Mac's
politics have been will say two years
from now they're gonna and I'm like I'm
not so sure you know it's something it's
a little different this time yeah what
is that do you don't know I'm not sure
instead Lindsey Buckingham has spent the
year putting together a retrospective of
his solo work and will tour behind it
into the new year you're enjoying being
on the road by yourself I'm not someone
who necessarily likes to look back I
like to look forward and that certainly
served me well this year but I was quite
taken by curating a 35 year plus body of
work to be able to go out and celebrate
that has been really very cathartic yeah
so I am having a great time